hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole
bunch of news about season 7 Dan and
Dave themselves were previewing some of
the big story arts there's going to be a
breakdown of that they started casting
some people so a whole bunch of stuff
the way Dan and Dave are talking about
it they're just like really happy that
the story is finally starting to
contract on itself
George R Martin talked about this -
about how the beginning of the story a
lot of the main characters all start out
in the same place then even like
physically emotionally they all start to
travel apart from each other like
everybody gets broken apart at the end
of season 1 at the end of book 1 after
Ned Stark gets killed characters like
aria end up going to the east eventually
so they are literally very far apart
from each other and then like people
like John and Sansa as they start to
come back together or emotionally very
far apart but as the story gets on
everybody starts to converge everyone's
interests start to align as the White
Walkers start to move in because they're
the ultimate threat they're really like
the representation of death in the
narrative like death is coming for
everyone eventually there's nothing you
can do to stop it so you might as well
start working together but we're only in
season seven so we've really only
started the process of bringing
everybody back together wouldn't it be
crazy if there were a scene eventually
like in the final season where everybody
that was still alive all the main
characters ended up in the same room
together I don't think that'll ever
happen but just like imagine Jaime
Cersei John Sansa Arya anybody else
that's still alive just all sitting in
the same room trying not to kill each
other they've already started casting
some new people I wanted to do a casting
video but most of the people that
they're casting are really minor
characters there are only a couple of
them that have speaking parts there are
like a couple noble characters but it
doesn't seem like anybody from the books
I know everybody wants to see Marwyn the
mage down in the citadel just remains to
be seen how much stuff from the books
that they're going to include because
just like last season even though they
moved past the book story for some
characters they did circle back around
and do a big Jaime plot in the
Riverlands that they had skipped before
so they might do the same thing with
other little bits from the books but for
the most part all the characters now are
past their book plot so when we talk
about theories and things that are
happening in season seven and eight it's
all going to be based on stuff the show
is doing in the direction the books are
headed because the really fun thing if
anybody tells you that you don't need to
read the books any
more because the show has passed it slap
them in the face because on an emotional
level the character arcs are still going
to be the same it's just that they're
physically going to be walking around in
different places so the plots going to
be a little bit different but the way
characters make decisions the places
that they end up at the end will be the
same but there are a couple of new
locations that look kind of like King's
Landing where we might see Daenerys and
her fleet moving in there are a couple
water-based locations in Spain that look
like they're going to be doubling for
King's Landing
it could be someplace in the south but
remember Daenerys has a big fleet so
we'll be seeing them come in and then
we'll also be seeing them leave like
they'll be arriving and departing from a
couple different locations a lot of
people actually heard that bit from the
season 7 teaser trailer when Tyrion said
welcome home my queen he's obviously
talking to Daenerys he's welcoming her
home to Westeros but I also think you
know the big teaser is is that he's
welcoming her home to King's Landing
like this is your home that you were
kicked out of when you were a baby so
just keep in mind that they haven't
really started shooting season seven yet
so that little bit that they put in the
teaser trailer the audio was pre shot so
it might change in the final version but
there'll be like a version of that where
Tyrion makes some offhanded Tyrion style
joke as they sail into King's Landing in
Daenerys starts walking towards the red
keep so the fun part we have like the
three big forces in King's Landing
between Jon Snow Cersei in tenaris Dan
and Dave kind of broke them down from
like a game prep perspective like next
year's going to be a three-way trial by
combat so the way they talk about
Daenerys they call it the dragon queen
and I'm reading from what they said
danny has a boundless confidence in
herself and her mission in this world
her sense of destiny
makes her a compelling charismatic
leader a messianic figure for the
multitudes meaning they kind of think of
first like a Jesus figure she has
arguably the cleverest advisor on the
planet
Tyrion Lannister she has three dragons
in army of unsullied and a great
Dothraki horde and then they tease what
could possibly go wrong meaning that a
bunch of stuff is going to go wrong for
her
so that teaser is like a whole video in
and of itself so which have to remember
to circle back around for that then they
go on to Cersei they call her the lone
lion
Circe will do anything to win in the
past the only factor limiting her
ruthlessness was her love for her
children now that her children are gone
nothing restraints her as she herself
said love is weakness a loveless Circe
is a fearsome thing so right away
everybody in King's Landing is in deep
including Jaime so then they move
on to their Jon Snow and night king
preview up in the north like the forces
up in the north and they refer to Jon
Snow as the white wolf saying Jon's
honourable nature has proven a
disadvantage in some regards a man who
plays by the rules will have a harder
time defeating men and women who do not
but John's nature also provides one of
his greatest strengths his ability to
win others to his cause the question
will be whether an honorable man can
overcome dishonorable enemies and then
they just briefly talk about the night
king his strength he can raise the dead
and have them do his bidding weaknesses
he'll never be as funny as the Ice King
and they're talking about Adventure Time
so Danny day likely to this interview
where they talked about how Adventure
Time like they've gone on drunken rants
about how Adventure Time is one of the
best shows of all time as well as Rick
and Morty so I just love the idea that
they casually slip you know like the
people that are creatively responsible
for shepherding Game of Thrones on
television are really in love with
Adventure Time and Rick and Morty so
just think about that for a second if
you've never watched either of those TV
shows be sure to check them out they're
both amazing but of the two I'm a little
more obsessed with Rick and Morty maybe
that means we'll see like a mr. poopy
butthole cameo in season 8 who knows as
for flashbacks those those always a big
question there's a couple of locations
that I talked about that look like they
could double for tourney at Harrenhal so
I'll link those videos at the end of
this but the really cool thing is is
that once October sets in they will
actually be shooting the show so within
the next four weeks or so we'll probably
be seeing some stuff from behind the
scenes although they always try to be
really careful but if you remember all
the stuff like all of the Tower of joy
stuff leaked early last year so if you
really like seeing behind the scenes
Game of Thrones filming stuff as it
happens that will probably start
dropping pretty soon but let me know
which characters that the books have cut
out so far do you want the TV show to do
keep in mind that there probably don't
have time to do the young grift
storyline so I'm not expecting any of
those characters but I do think that
Marwyn the mage is possible in any of
the big northern Lords from the books
that they have not done in the north yet
like Laura to fat to sit a horse so
giveaway time congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner billy bat you win
a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there is a new round that starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video if you guys have any requests for
bonus videos just leave them below in
the comments
new video posting tonight so while you
guys wait for that you can click here
for more Game of Thrones season 7 and
you can click here to learn all about
mary jane and spider-man homecoming
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you